so
our last caller you and i and and a
bunch of you riding around in your car
we're thinking about that one
going into the break dad passes away at
69
leaves 750 000 to mom plus a pension
plus a pension and um
paid for house and had done a really
good job
and um now his son
and mom are trying to figure out you
know how to invest and what to do
um that guy did a great job that's a
legacy yep
that's a legacy the first thing when
when we hung up the phone went to break
the first thought of my mind was
i hope i set my wife up like that that's
the goal right
i know i'm not going to be here i hope
that that's the conversation they're
having
her and my son yeah i mean you know what
the conversation normally is
is how do we pay for the funeral dave
i've sat with so
many i can't even count them how many
people i've sat with who have lost their
spouse
and they're looking at me in the eyes
and there's this particular look
and they say the words i don't know what
to do
and i'm sitting there it's the middle of
the night and
i i don't know what to tell you because
i don't know what i would do either
you know what i mean manufacture eight
thousand dollars for a funeral i don't
know where it's gonna come from wow
because
i yolo'd my wife my life away right you
only live once thank god it's friday oh
god it's monday
you can't take it with you and you
freaking child
you immature little brat you selfish
individual and you have absolutely no
legacy because of it none
i mean one definition of maturity is
learning to delay pleasure
live like no one else so later you can
live and give like no one else it
doesn't say you don't have a life
i have had a wonderful life i've done
anything i wanted to do and i've
completely set my family up
right those aren't mutually exclusive
they don't have to be
right it doesn't have to be the you know
i live in a cave click lent only come
out on triple coupon thursday
right i don't have a life at all and
that's the only way you build wealth
that is not how most people build wealth
most people build wealth while they're
having a good life
they just paid attention pay attention
and
there's this this consumer mentality for
kids especially
we got to buy our kids this buy our kids
that the new xbox just came out and it's
111
million dollars there's xbox some yeah
playstation whatever it is
can i tell you what happened last night
my wife said hey john
um our daughter josephine she's gonna be
five here next couple weeks
she just needs you and i know what that
means
so i went and found josephine and said i
challenge you
and her eyes got real big and excited
and she has made this sword
out of the inside of a
uh like a presence wrapper you know like
a wrapping paper oh
yeah though yeah and we had a sword
fight for about an hour to where i'm so
sore
broken it didn't she was hitting and
what
it was incredible then you find out she
put a broomstick inside it
yeah that's right beat her dad lost no
money
we had a great hour together bedtime was
much better this morning was better
and so you're talking about what's
legacy that we bought another
with wiggly d box or we had some time to
go fishing and i put some money in
retirement i was able to save i was able
to do these things that when
not if but when it happens when i just
suddenly pass away
that my wife my son and my daughter are
saying how we can invest this money not
what are we gonna do
a godly man leaves an inheritance to his
children's children
proper obsessed and
you know so it is a different
grieving process when there's a pile of
money there
money does not make them come back i
trade all the money just to have them
back i
understand you don't get to make that
trade these aren't trades you can make
so it's not an option that's not
it's not one or the other that's not how
this works it's just saying
money gives you margin you have room to
grieve
you cannot do enough crying
when you immediately have to go to work
to keep the lights on yep
i mean tomorrow morning you got to go to
work when your 65 year old mom has to go
find a job
tomorrow morning right after he died
yesterday that's right
because there's no money for the for the
light bill yep
i mean this is where people are this is
where a lot of people are
and and no one planned to be there
at all they didn't plan not to be there
i know that's exactly where i was going
the ones that aren't there planned to
not be there that's right
it's exactly right i i just want people
listening to this as you're driving or
mowing the yard or walking around
whatever you're doing
i'm telling you i've looked in the eyes
of countless people who have said the
words i don't know what to do and don't
let that be
your family legacy and what they really
mean is not only do i not know how to
process this grief
without this broken heart that i have
right now due to losing this person
but they're also saying i don't even
know how i'm going to bury them i don't
know how to bury them i don't know where
their papers are at their job i don't
know where
our bills are because we don't haven't
communicated in 15 or 20 or 30 or 40
years
i just don't know what to do and that's
about having legacy conversations that's
about having a will that's about all
that stuff dave and
it distills down to one word
intentionality yep
just that one word be intentional dad in
the last
call is a hero he is a hero he did a
great job
if i was going to coach him up and
you're him out there that
is listening you haven't died yet that
means you're listening right
i would add a couple things to his plan
okay
mom's clueless that's right he shouldn't
left mom clueless
mom and him should have been meeting
with the investment counselor
and saying here's what happens and let
me just tell you that's what sharon
ramsey does
she knows she's gonna the the the first
call
is gonna be to the smart vester pro the
second one will be the coroner
[Laughter]
right i mean she knows exactly where her
bread is buttered right i make podcast
series out of these
situations dave you know that's really
what's gonna happen
yeah and um you know she is
uh not an investment professional i am
right
but she has enough understanding and she
knows exactly who to talk to
and so she doesn't have to have this oh
my god i have this money and i'm scared
by the money
right moment and so one thing you can
add to that last hero's
story is i'd like for him to have
trained mom
and had the counselor the coach the
advisor the smartvestor pro
in mom's corner already where they
didn't call dave ramsey
didn't need me yep didn't didn't call dr
deloney because it didn't need you had
that
dialed in and just pick up the phone
call at smartvestor pro because
this is what we've talked about for the
last 10 years as we've been doing our
investing there
and we talked about mutual funds and we
talked about we don't do these and we do
do these and
here's how you pick a mutual fund and
the very basics
of investing where you have a basic
rudimentary understanding you don't have
to be an
have an mba in finance and um
my wife was a full-time mom for 30
six years now you know so she's not an
investment professional right
she's very intelligent very capable of
understanding the concepts and does
have you had this conversation with your
kids oh yeah as well yep
that's a great gift that my dad gave me
was sitting down saying
here's where stuff is here's where the
box is where all my stuff
goes um if something happens to me and
sharon together
they know exactly which drawer that's
right i've got the drawer at the house
we call it the legacy drawer it's where
everything is
every piece of paper every all the the
wheels the trusts
the legal documents on the properties
and we go over that once a year have a
little meeting with everybody
you know uh ours is a wee bit
complicated of course
but you know you can my family is this
simple all you gotta do
is just say here's what to do and here's
how to do it and here's
and then that adds yet another level of
peace 750
000 adds a level of peace knowledge adds
another level of peace
that's what i want you people to do i
want you to love
your family well with being diligent in
these things
this is the dave ramsey show